now some people the one consolation here
we sometimes talk about the conservative
consolation is that reality reasserts
itself
in the end well reality is for some
people reasserting itself there is a
walk away rally in beverly hills
walk away rallies the whole walkway
movement is this idea that the various
identity groups that have been divvied
up
by the left are kind of waking up to the
con and saying wait a second
the left the democrats don't really
support my interests
so they're going to walk away and
they're going to vote for republicans so
there was some woke white liberal
guy who was scolding some black woman
about how it's against her
racial or gender interests to vote for
republicans
and this woman i don't know her name but
she let him have it
my life matters i don't need your
privilege to tell me
or to justify who i am in america this
is my country
this is my name
[Applause]
so i'm gonna walk around here as bold as
i want to
and i don't have
but you are supporting an organization
that does not like black men
and as a black woman i can tell you how
important black men
are to the black family without them we
are nothing
love her totally love her want her to
run for mayor of l.a or beverly hills or
whatever
she gets it right down to the bottom so
this
this white liberal kid is talking about
how great black lives matter is she goes
you don't know anything about black
lives or black lives matter for that
matter black lives matter is terrible
for black people
black lives matter is terrible for a
great many reasons but
in particular because it wants to
subvert the family
it's very bad for black men and
if you're supporting the destruction of
the black family then you're
as bad as anybody you're totally
destroying black lives
she gets two things here that
the the left is relying on to divvy up
the country and gain more power
one is the left wants diversity so they
push this
ridiculous line diversity is our
strength and what they mean by diversity
is truly
division they want people to feel
totally separated diversity
in that sense is not our strength unity
is our strength
there's an older idea in america called
a pluribus unum
out of many one that we all come
together there's the idea of the melting
pot which developed in the 20th century
the idea that we all come together from
maybe from different places but we all
melt together into an american culture
we are united we because we maybe we
don't look to say maybe we don't do
exactly the same things
but we do have an american unity we've
got to come together that's the only way
to fight leftist politics some
conservatives maybe they're well-meaning
but certainly they're naive
they think we can beat the left on
identity politics grounds
they think that we'll be able to claim
identity group loyalty to us so so
they'll do it they do it often with
black people they'll say
democrats say that black people must
vote for democrats but we say black
people must vote for republicans
or they'll say gay people democrats
aren't representing your interests we
are vote for us gay people
it's actually missing the point the
point is
we are americans we're all americans you
should vote for the party that supports
america
not the party that burns the american
flag and tears down statues of george
washington
but we are all americans this woman says
it she goes this is my country
oh democrats they get so angry they get
furious
when their pet identity politics groups
acknowledge that america is their
country feel loyalty and gratitude for
america
they don't like that but it's true this
is our country all together
you should vote for the party that
supports the country not the party
that wants to tear the country down and
then what she realizes is the importance
of
institutions not just starting at the
level of the federal government not just
the state
not just the municipal government not
even just the voluntary associations
the family the family the building block
of society
the only thing between you and the
tyrannical government the family
it's not some people think that the
basic building block of society
is the atomized individual some people
think
it's the collective overall those are
two sides of the same coin
the left can only gather you up into one
collective once they've split you up
from all of your institutions most
importantly the family
into atomized individuals that's what
how communism operates that's how
fascism operates
fascism literally comes from the
description of the bundle of sticks
that they're all separate and then
they're bounded together in the state
the family is what will protect you this
woman gets it
we should all get it too i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]